good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this special press conference
after special meeting of the European
Council without further ado I invite the
President of the European Council to
take it from was it special let me first
of all thank you for your patience I
know that it has taken us longer than
planned but we are still on time we have
agreed the whole package before the
first session of the European Parliament
five years ago we needed three months to
the site and still some leaders were
against this year it was three days and
nobody was against even if Germany
abstained on the commission president
due to some issues in the government
coalition personally Chancellor Merkel
supported the whole package first and
foremost we have chosen two women and
two men for the four key positions a
perfect gentleman's I'm really happy
about it after all you're a busy woman
I think it was worth waiting for
such an outcome we have proposed or
sulla von der Leyen of the next
president of the European Commission and
nominated Christine Lagarde of the
candidate for president of the European
Central Bank we have selected Sharma
shell of the next president of the
European Council and president of the
Euro Summit as well as nominated to that
peril of the candidate for high
representative of the Union for Foreign
Affairs and security policy
it will now be for the European
Parliament to consider or Salaf on the
lion for the commission president if
elected she will be the first woman to
lead the European Commission
Jean Michel will with his experience as
Belgian prime minister be ideal for
finding consensus and building
you need a monk member-states just a
barrel will as foreign minister and
former president of the European
Parliament be a strong representative
and defender of the European Union's
interest and values in the world
Christine Lagarde will with an
international background and standing as
current managing director of the
International Monetary Fund be a perfect
president of the European Central Bank
in addition the European Council took
note of forceful Lafond Alliance
intentions to nominate France
Timmerman's and Margaret s target as the
high-ranking vice president of the
Commission we also expect Ursula from
the line to ensure an appropriate
geographical balance in the team of vice
president I wish the new leaders all the
best thank you thank you I now open the
floor for your questions Georgian you
have to first yes hello president I got
from your active how about the
Parliament I mean I know it's it's it's
not you it's the Parliament but it was
anyway part of the package so you didn't
mention what are the names that were
discussed for the European Parliament
president obviously dividing the mandate
into to you you must be aware that the
name of Sergey Tanisha for example is
circulating can you elaborate
for obvious reasons I want to be as
delicate as possible we know that this
is for the Parliament to decide on the
names our intention is to to have an
president of the Parliament from the
Socialists and Democrats for the first
time and candidate from the EPP for the
second time but this is our political
opinion and our political intention but
we were and really it was a all of the
readers underlines that they awareness
that this is only for the Parliament to
decide of it thank you yes thank you
Silvia matter from CNBC looking at the
CV the next president the presidency of
ECB is actually quite a technical role
do you think that given that Madame
Lagarde was a minister for finance in
France doesn't that actually put at risk
the independence of the ECB thank you
I have known Madame Lagarde for many
years and I'm absolutely sure that she
will be a very independent president of
the European Central Bank right
good evening my paper cone foreskin
Netherlands actually it's two questions
first of all do you think that it's
Encana doesn't model now is completely
ready to be buried and secondly do you
foresee the possibility of another
package is there a possibility in the
case European Parliament says we don't
want this Thanks no I am NOT a prophet
it's not for me to assess what is the
real chance to achieve success in the
Parliament I will be the in Strasbourg
on test day and I will inform and
explain everything I like I can about
this process and our intentions but of
Cour right it's always a huge question
market this is why we have Parliament I
mean to debate or discuss to argue and
then to decide but I hope that of course
that the political leaders not only
Prime Minister Prime Minister's will do
everything to to convince our colleagues
in the Parliament to support this this
project when it comes to spittin candy
Dutton it was clear from the very
beginning that for the European Council
potemkin data and procedure is not the
form of self obligation it's not a legal
obligation but we wanted to respect
candidates idea of leading candidates
and I think that the final result is a
demonstration that
that we wanted to respect both people
and this mechanism thank you and Jim
you'll get the last question thank you
very much Jim Bronstein from the
Financial Times the candidates who have
been chosen for their for the lead jobs
they hail from France Germany other
member states in Belgium are the Member
States in in Western Europe geographical
balance was one of your major aims in
the negotiations how well do you feel
you succeeded our function is that it's
still possible maybe something more
maybe light we're lucky that in the
Parliament there's still chance that the
Parliament will vote for a president
from the eastern and central Europe this
is I hope so at least but of course it's
not fast to decide on this and just two
minutes ago I said also that we wanted
to encourage sulla from the line to to
propose an appropriate geographical
balance in the team of vice-president
and you know if someone asks me what it
means I would answer that Central and
Eastern Europe as well as Italy should
be on board in this process thank you
very much
this concludes the press conference
thank you